do you already have a community when
you're doing this we're just making
videos for the ether because there's no
one really there just kind of creating
it how was it like I had a website yeah
uh and I put up some my videos on the
website there on the website not it
wasn't like a just the YouTube channel
where you were getting people from was
mainly from your website at that point
yeah it was from the website but I
didn't put all of them up i only put a
select few on the website and then when
i answered somebody's question i would
send him the link to the video response
so that they could see the response that
i gave them but i didn't push my channel
hard to my existing community I wanted
to be able to live on its own you know
like I'm doing you know I'm doing
snapchat right now right like I'm not
pushing it hard to my community yet I
wanted to be able to live on its own and
if it does and I can blow it up so even
now if you go to my website there's some
of the videos on there but it's still
mostly a content-based website so my
website exist the youtube channel exists
is a little bit of cross-pollination
promotion but it doesn't have to be
there most of the most of the growth on
youtube came from organic reach